Google put more than just that in it like
for instance my
My omelets I like to put cheese egg meat
onions bell peppers and you might like it a
little bit cuz some people like
Jalapenos in there some people like putting
hash browns in there
Cuz I don't do it I don't do it
So I know you ain't had it cuz the only ones
that made omelets and my money make me know
omelets I don't remember your mama making no
omelette
I don't remember your mama making no helmets
the last person to make me an omelette was
Vivian Vivian made me an omelette
That thing y'all had that little egg pocket
thing that's omelette
Yeah it tastes like a breakfast sandwich
So like really I would like to do it like
that make The Omelette then put the omelette
in between two pieces of bread and then
cheese
OneCheese. And then toasted bread.
Yeah other than that it was perfect
Like I have one yeah cuz the more you put in
the thing the harder it actually gets to
flip
It's Donald Trump's here
Bro does that mean you
Are you doing thatIt doing.
Everything by itself
When I left today it was still moving on his
own cuz that's when Chris told me he was
fine
I remember it was clicking the stuff and it
was a pasty stuff in and yeah that's all I
remember
For real cuz I remember Chris came over at
Christmas like is the my music and I was
like oh you right and I saw the mouse moving
I was like oh I can't touch because the
mouse moving and he was like okay I was like
I don't know so watch what you say and it
was like all right
Okay
Try to get in there and mute it
Cuz I at that's when I'm not here that's
y'all's privacy it's not
But make sure you put this on it next time
not this one food
It's no it wasn't yesterday was this one
And then if they can here
Not only that but it saves y'all's
transcripts
And I'm going to go back and look at them to
see what y'all said and it's going to say
when you said it it's not going to say who
said it
But I'mma catch all that person you know
Why the fuck not
You think that stuff your activity yeah if
you don't know yeah oh
Yeah I know would notLike.
I know not
What is it always catch you it don't be but
no it don't always catch you or it catch
Chris cuz he's specifically face the camera
he specifically loud and he come over and he
started talking like it didn't catch him
when he was over there and then he came back
and then it started catching him again
Your own voice imagine you can go back
period
I'm just crazyMr Crystal.
That don't matter Chris it's the street this
is the Christian it's the crystal I don't
care it don't matter
Just talk normal I don't want you to stopI
want you to talk normal.
Because it's once you raise Above This level
right right about here once you with that 50
like the 40 whatever this Market
This catch is it
But when it's higher than that it definitely
catchesSo. So.
My average speaking tone is just barely
enough to get caught so that I don't got to
Force my voice to be louderI like that. But
Chris is natural too it's about here.
So I've already clocked it I know exactly
how loud Chris talksIt's just much lower
than me.
If you talk regular we would fucking know
but you know now you want to try to use some
sort of I don't know what that is
But just talk normal
No come back
The one who always had something to say
Then the moment when I'm like Chris please
be quiet it's not the Chris show Chris won't
be that he going to tell us about everything
possible he going to tell us the inner
thoughts of everything oh I'm balancing on
the ball I need to stand left I need to move
to the right a little bit oh it's kind of
cold in here no you literally do that
UglyFinally.
Got comfortable
How you got a whisper and I can talk on it
about to whisper
ManPicture. Yeah it's not a swisher.
It catch thatVideo.
All the way over there works out perfect
But it's okayThey going to have a Chris show
or part of the show that's going to be for
Chris. Yeah.
Chris Colton
A branch system so that I can
Give each agent their own individualBranch.
And thenTry to see if we can use that too.
I wonder does it make it better if I do it
like thatOr did that make it more sensitive.
I also wonder what it sounds like on the
screen
Not like yeah I don't know I can't I don't
know what we sound like on the screen
So let's yeah you want video
When you want video your voice sound
different than what you can hear
What do you think
Anything
So even when it doesn't record it still
catches
The captainI mean not the caption. They can
still hear it.
That's a good ass microphone
But at least the captions aren't catching
you
And I was with me kind of like shouting this
is just like me brainstorming right here
No no wait I may just bring it back because
it's
No they could do the frequency started going
crazy
Alcohol all day I can't get your word but
you're thinking here Chris all the way from
the front door
See that's perfect but not perfect
I've been screaming for 16 hoursAll right
I'm saying let's not.
It is today the day
You said it was moving stuff brother
S back in the motion agents who activate
I thank youYou know how to cook eggs.
You know how to make you know how to
makeSure.
No more than two three
Or four minutes
I got to wear headphones
Do you know howYou know how to chop them up.
?
I want to see if the sound
Oh cuz my why is my speakers broke if y'all
keep messing with my speaker
Why we need the blue charger let me borrow
the way when y'all are using
Your thing
OhNo well.
You got to make sure that you put it lined
up so I can go back inside
Yes it isI can do it I just need you to hand
me the charger until you do all that.
Okay go ahead grab it on my room I can turn
that little red light that red light off
it's a red light that's still on in there
right
Let me see if it's going to workWhat is the.
Oh I'm sorry you called me while I was
playing the video game I have the agents
working so I pretty much have a system that
allows
The agents to talk to the agents and that's
what I'm working on so that's why you don't
see any code up because I'm not trying to
code I'm trying to work as straight as
system where the agents code themselves and
so the cool thing is
Cursor exists pretty much but
No this is me Victor and I am the guy behind
the screen I just happened to hear the
chatty notifications so I unmute it the mic
but I was playing the video game with the
kids while the agents have been going
Thanks appreciate it and so
Yeah I'm actually sorry I'm going to go back
to playing the video games but I have the
agents working right now and so the way it
works pretty much is this agent agent for
right here normally commands the squad I
probably should get it to
Keep going but bro holler
Either way I just wanted to explain because
I know when people come in they don't
understand but no what I'm working on right
here is what I call the agent cell phone
system and so the messages you see like this
message right here was sent from another
agent when I do get back to the computer I'm
a set it back up to where you can you can
see which agent sent it to which agent but
right now I have eight agents open so eight
cursor interface is open and they were
working on consolidating the project because
when you have eight different AI agents
working without somebody watching it
basically
If they like to duplicate and over complex
things and so I'm trying to see if I can
prompt that out and basically turn this into
a workflow and I know I can especially for
like like pie testing and like things like
that like or let's say for instance I
already know exactly what I want to build
like this will speed it up times eight I'd
like to say
But you knowI just I only seem to play with
this toy so I can't really say that it's
beneficial yet.
Either way that's my little baby that's my
little project I hope you liked it I hope
you understand maybe I might come back some
other time but peace out becoming